president biden says new york governor
andrew cuomo should resign
if the sexual harassment allegations
against him are proven true
and he says cuomo could be in legal
jeopardy as well
correspondent brian yennis has our
report tonight from brooklyn
tonight governor cuomo reacted to
president joe biden's sharpest criticism
yet against him
amid multiple sexual harassment
allegations
if the investigation confirms the claims
of the women
should he resign yes i think he probably
ended up being prosecuted too
cuomo touted a recent siena college poll
which found 50 percent of new york
voters believe the governor
should not immediately resign 35 percent
say he should
cuomo was also asked about a report by
the new york times
that he helped draft a letter intended
to smear lindsey boylan
the first woman to publicly accuse him
of sexual misconduct
but cuomo did not answer citing the
current impeachment investigation
underway in the state assembly i'm not
going to comment
until those reviews are finished on any
specific
issue that they're looking at the times
reports the letter quote
was a full-on attack on ms boylan's
credibility suggesting that her
accusation was premeditated and
politically motivated
it disclosed personnel complaints filed
against her
and attempted to link her to supporters
of former president donald j
trump cuomo's team reportedly circulated
the letter for female signatures
knowing another age charlotte bennett
had privately accused cuomo of the same
behavior
boylan tweeted governor cuomo tried to
destroy me when i spoke my truth about
his abuse
earlier today cuomo received his johnson
and johnson vaccination
shot flanked by black leaders including
former new york democratic congressman
charlie rangel
who defended his friend you can make any
allegation that you want to make
but due process and a hearing
is basically what we believe in
in this country
tonight critics say the law firm davis
polk and wardwell that
has been tapped to lead the impeachment
investigation governor cuomo has a
conflict of interest they say
a former influential partner has close
ties to the cuomo administration
and is married to a chief judge
appointed by cuomo
brett brian yenis in brooklyn brian
thanks